the opening scene takes place at a
Medical University where a professor is
seen lecturing his students during this
a female student named Sunita comes
across a report about a man suffering
from anterograde Amnesia she tries to
delve into it but the professor forbids
her saying the case is being handled by
the police however when Sunita keeps on
insisting he reveals that the patient's
name is Sanjay singhania a former
business executive who now suffers from
severe memory loss according to the
professor Sanjay's memory is limited to
just 15 minutes leading him to rely on
photographs notes and tattoos on his own
body to remember things around him the
movie then shifts to Sanjay who is shown
beating up a guy ruthlessly after
finishing him off he captures a picture
of the guy and takes a note in his small
notebook Sanjay then examines his phone
and discovers the name gajini which
triggers vague memories from his past it
is evident that he is looking for this
particular man after he leaves both the
police team led by inspector Arjun and a
group of gangsters arrive at the crime
scene each searching for Sanjay later we
see Sanjay waking up in his cluttered
house filled with mementos and notes
related to hunting down gajini he
proceeds to the bathroom where a
reminder on the mirror prompts him to
remove his shirt as he does so his body
is revealed to be covered in tattoos
that serve as aids to trigger Memories
the biggest tattoo on his chest reads
kalpana was killed and the second
biggest says an apple a day keeps the
doctor away later in the day Sanjay
visits a Medical College where Sunita
approaches him and curiously asks about
his condition however Sanjay refuses to
disclose anything stating that they are
not France Sunita persuades him to take
her photographs so that he may remember
her when she approaches him the next
time later as Sanjay is reading his
notes at home Arjun cover overtly sneaks
in from behind and knocks him out with a
bat the officer then ties him up and
strips him in search of additional Clues
during the search of the entire place he
discovers a couple of Diaries as Arjun
reads the first one the scene
transitions to a flashback that reveals
Sanjay's past life as the chairman of a
prominent cell phone company called air
voice turns out he was a
multi-millionaire who was respected and
adored by everyone around him in the
next segment of the flashback we are
introduced to kapana a struggling model
who is running late for her detergent ad
Shoot kapana who is known for her
mischievous nature deliberately messes
up the ad causing the director to scold
her elsewhere Sanjay is occupied with
his work searching for a suitable
location to place a billboard for his
company after a long search she finally
finds a good spot which happens to be
where kalpana resides so Sanjay
instructs his assistant to approach
kalpana regarding the billboard
placement at her place as the employees
head studio for this purpose they
encounter satvir the director of the ad
film who is surprised to learn that they
represent the air voice company Seth
Veer seizes the opportunity to promote
his own small business hoping to
collaborate on a larger scale but he
soon realizes that the team is only
interested in meeting kalpana in the
next scene the meeting takes place and
all the employees in the company
eavesdrop on their conversation with
curiosity kalpana declines air voices
offer saying she hates rich people like
Sanjay but the people outside mistakenly
hear that Sanjay is her boyfriend
somehow so as soon as she comes out of
the room all of her colleagues and even
the director begin treating her with
special attention kalpana is a bit
perplexed by their Sudden Change in
attitude but she decides to take full
advantage of it she plays along with the
rumor and as the days pass by the
director gives her leading roles in
several advertisements one day kalpana
fabricates a fictional love story and
shares it with with a reporter who
publishes it on the news this results in
an influx of phone calls at Sanjay's
office causing him to feel annoyed in
order to put an end to the rumor he
finally decides to confront kalpana
while on his way to the shoot Studio
Sanjay spots kalpana who is currently
helping disabled children cross a
pothole he doesn't know that she is the
same person involved in the rumor so he
is greatly impressed but once he enters
the studio and meets kalpana he is taken
aback the mischievous girl who is also
unaware of Sanjay's true identity
proudly boasts about being his lover she
mentions that they have been on several
dates together and are soon getting
married hearing all this Sanjay Chuckles
gently and decides to play along for now
he pretends to be an auditioner the next
day he is in the midst of an interview
when he suddenly receives a call from
kalpana offering him an underwear
advertisement Sanjay has a really hectic
schedule aligned for the day but he's
still chooses to visit her perhaps he is
fallen for kalpana's charm and innocence
or perhaps he's just tickled by the word
underwear following this he gets into an
auto rickshaw and takes a ride through
the not so wealthy part of the city
which is crammed and polluted Sanjay is
not used to this environment so he feels
a bit uneasy however his face lights up
when he meets kalpana as they make their
way to the studio she encounters a
visually impaired man whom she assists
in reaching the bus stop this reveals
that although kalpana is a mischievous
girl she has a heart of gold Sanjay is
also infatuated by her kindness and so
from that day onward the two spend more
time together gradually growing closer
one day kalpana meets satvir who informs
her about a New Year's party taking
place at their Studio much to her
surprise the director requests her to
invite her boyfriend as the chief guest
initially panicked kalpana devises a
plan to find someone who can pose as
Sanjay she then contact attacks an
eccentric weirdo and trains him to
impersonate the rich businessman however
as she is instructing The Imposter the
real Sanjay arrives and bursts into
laughter upon being introduced to the
odd substitute kalpana caught in her lie
confesses to the entire charade and
requests Sanjay attend the party posing
as Sanjay singhania this makes our
protagonists laugh even more as he is
being requested to impersonate himself
so just for the fun of it he agrees at
the party Sanjay makes a grand entrance
in his luxurious car which surprises
kalpana as it surpasses their initial
plan while they are having dinner a
group of Charity workers arrive seeking
donations Sanjay generously takes out
his checkbook and donates 500 000 to the
cause leaving kapana in shock but
despite this unexpected act she still
fails to sense anything amiss following
the party the two board a local bus to
return home kalpana is chattering about
the success of their plan when suddenly
Sanjay says I love you catching her
completely off guard with a nervous face
she then asks for time to think about it
after kalpana departs Sanjay decides
that he will win her heart as an
ordinary man and if she agrees he'll
reveal his true identity back in the
present Arjun completes reading the
first Diary but before he reads the
second one he is interrupted as Sanjay
regains Consciousness and launches an
attack on him a fierce fight ensuse and
as the barbaric Sanjay is about to
inflict a fatal blow on the inspector
the doorbell rings upon answering it
Sanjay finds his former assistant and
his doctor they mention that they want
to help him but Sanjay declines and
closes the door the following day a
reminder prompts Sanjay to carry out his
plan to kill his enemy he infiltrates a
college Festival where gajini is the
chief guest and a prominent benefactor
as the event begins a staff member
welcomes God Genie and Sanjay takes a
photograph of him shortly afterward he
calls God Genie summoning him to the
basement but since the latter is busy he
sends one of his men instead Sanjay
mistakes the man for gajini and brutally
beats him up however upon comparing the
picture with the man's face he realizes
that he took out the wrong guy suddenly
gajini arrives there with his armed
henchmen prompting Sanjay to run away
without revealing his face this makes
the intimidating villain realize that
someone is after him so he decides to
compile a list of his enemies names and
eliminate them one by one in the next
scene Sunita visits Sanjay's apartment
and quietly enters when she finds the
door open she notices reminders of
Revenge scattered everywhere and picks
up his Diaries after this she shockingly
discovers Arjun Bound in a closet Sunni
to quickly freeze him but as they
prepare to escape Sanjay shows up with
no memory of who they are Arjun manages
to flee but he is unfortunately struck
by a bus killing him on the spot now the
clueless Sanjay starts chasing Sunita
through the busy streets of Mumbai but
once he loses his memory she approaches
him again claiming to be a friend
elsewhere gajini despite eliminating all
of his enemies still senses that someone
is missing as fate would have it Sunita
visits him the same day and reveals that
Sanjay is planning to kill him she even
provides him with a photograph of Sanjay
before departing armed with this
information gajini sets out to eliminate
his final enemy within the next 12 hours
the following day Sanjay tracks down
sanita's hostile room and immediately
grabs her by the neck however she
somehow manages to break free and run
away in an act of desperation she then
traps him into the elevator and contacts
the police the plan works as the cops
soon arrive and apprehends Sanjay later
Sunita recalls the Diaries she stole
from Sanjay's place she begins reading
the first one just like the inspector
and learns about Sanjay and kalpana's
story then she proceeds to the second
diary and the movie once again goes into
flashback kalpana and Sanjay are
together at a romantic Park where she
suddenly accepts his proposal this makes
our Rich hero excited but as he is about
to disclose his true identity kalpana
interrupts him and opens up about her
family she reveals that her father was
deceived by his uncle in a financial
matter this brought the family a lot of
hardship and pain so kalpana has decided
that she won't get married until and
unless she is financially stable upon
hearing this Sanjay also decides to
postpone revealing his true identity
later he calls his assistant and gives
him the keys to an apartment turns out
Sanjay was about to surprise kalpana
with this apartment as a gift but since
he couldn't reveal his identity after
all last thing he wants is for her to
know that he's financially stable he
asks his assistant to organize a lucky
draw and make coppana the winner this
way she will accept the apartment
without any questions in the following
scene kalpana is shown at a pawn shop
where she sell some of her jewelry to
obtain money with the money she receives
she fulfills one of her Dreams by
purchasing a second-hand Ambassador car
later she invites Sanjay to her new
apartment to share her happiness they
both step inside at the same time and
cement their Footprints as a memory with
the formalities done Sanjay reveals that
he will be leaving town for 10 days but
since he cannot tell her about his
urgent meeting he fabricates a story
Sanjay says that he has to go to his
village in order to sell some property
and fund his mother's medical treatment
later that night kalpana contacts Sanjay
requesting a brief meeting when he
arrives he is shocked to learn that she
has sold her car in order to manage
money for his mother's treatment this
deeply affects Sanjay as he feels
burdened by the weight of his own lies
he cannot stop thinking about her even
on the flight but in the present Sunita
is dejected to learn that Sanjay has not
written any events after this point her
curiosity about what trans inspired next
intensifies and she seeks out satvir to
discuss kalpana however he doesn't say
much and avoids her questions meanwhile
at the police station the authorities
conduct an investigation on Sanjay and
uncover the tattoos of memorabilia
scattered across his body in an attempt
to unveil his true identity they begin
dialing the numbers tattooed on his body
surprisingly one of the numbers belongs
to God Genie who is then summoned to the
police station gajini recognizes the man
right away and informs the officers that
he is Sanjay singhania the chairman of
their voice and a patient suffering from
short-term memory loss later Sanjay's
assistant and Doctor arrive at the
police station and provide evidence of
his innocence this convinces the cops
and he is eventually freed later that
night gajini and his men forcefully
enter Sanjay's residence only to find
him unconscious gajini realizes that
killing him would lead to their capture
by the police so he decides to erase any
memory related evidence from Sanjay's
body and his apartment instead meanwhile
Sunita and her friend conduct research
on Sanjay and kalpana eventually
locating a young girl who holds a
disturbing story from the past in a
flashback kapana encounters the same
girl inside a train clearly frightened
as she turns out to be hiding from Human
traffickers despite kalpana's attempts
to assist the child the gangsters snatch
her away kalpana even offers her gold
necklaces a bribe but the villains
refuse fortunately a compartment filled
with police officers intervenes
overpowering the criminals and rescuing
the other victimized girls this incident
gains widespread attention through the
news leading to the arrest of several
criminals one night a police Constable
contacts kalpana informing her about The
Disappearance of the two young girls
intrigued kalpana decides to investigate
but she encounters God Genie and his men
Instead The Notorious gangster admits to
killing those girls and disposing of
their bodies as they snitched about him
this enrageous kalpana so much that she
insults him badly before storming away
upon arriving back home she again
receives a call from the police
Constable who informs that gargini has
sent his Killers to execute her fearing
for her safety kalpana hides in a corner
of her apartment the Assassins break in
and starts searching for her throughout
the house meanwhile Sanjay returns from
his business trip and goes straight to
kalpana's apartment to meet her he rings
the doorbell and knocks multiple times
but there is no response assuming that
she is not home he decides to leave as
he gets into his car he notices multiple
missed calls from kalpana and calls her
back unfortunately her phone is not on
silent mode oh God causing it to ring
loud kapana hastily answers and explains
the dire situation prompting Sanjay to
quickly turn back and head to her place
shortly afterward he enters the
apartment and discovers kalpana in a
weakened State he rushes to her side and
Embraces her during which she Whispers
the name gajini in his ear this is no
time for dirty talk he says it is at
this moment that Sanjay realizes kalpana
has been stabbed in the back but before
he can react gajini walks into the room
and brutally strikes Sanjay's head with
an iron Rod he then finishes off kalpana
with a similar blow before pounding
Sanjay's head one more time the two
deadly shots to his skull are the reason
for his interrogate Amnesia although he
somehow survived the incident he has
been left scarred all his life but the
word god Genie that goes through his
mind all the time now he only wants one
thing revenge in the present Sunita who
has finally uncovered the truth feels
bad for Sanjay and visits him in the
hospital she reminds him of his gruesome
past causing him to break down in tears
but after a while Sanjay remembers his
mission and calls God Genie he tells the
gangster I am coming for you and hangs
up following this Sunita assists him in
locating gajini's hideout in a local
area and upon arrival Sanjay decides to
confront him alone he enters the
premises and engages in a fierce battle
with gajini's henchmen despite Sanjay
being weak and alone the memories of
kalpana and the feeling of Revenge are
enough to help him push further and the
fact that none of the henchmen have guns
also helps as Sanjay pummels the
villains one by one and Ventures deep
into the neighborhood Sunita follows
closely behind eventually he confronts
gajini and a brutal fight ensues between
the two adversaries Sanjay easily
overpowers the gangster even though the
latter has an army of henchmen when the
situation becomes dire gajini attempts
to flee but Sanjay relentlessly pursues
him along the way he subdues several
goons and it appears as if he is going
to get his man but just then his Amnesia
kicks in and he forgets all the events
that just transpired as Sanjay wanders
aimlessly through the alleys he
coincidentally stumbles upon gajini the
gangster realizes what's going on so he
pretends to be a friend but at an
opportune moment he stabs Sanjay from
behind and drops him to the ground so
you need to seize this and rushes to his
Aid only to receive a harsh backhanded
slap across the face now with both
Sanjay and Sunita on the ground gajini
grabs an iron rod and prepares to
reenact the tragic murder he inflicted
Upon kalpana This Time targeting cenita
however Sanjay unexpectedly throws the
same Rod that he had been stabbed with
towards gajini he then courageously gets
up fights the villain and brings him to
the ground with determination in his
eyes he grasps the iron rod and delivers
a single lethal blow finally achieving
his long-awaited revenge gagini is
finally dead in the madness is over
following this the movie cuts to six
months later we learned that Sanjay now
runs an orphanage which she is named in
honor of kalpana one day Sunita pays him
a visit and presents him with the cement
pad containing the foot impressions of
both Sanjay and kalpana from the past
this heartfelt gift brings a flurry of
emotions to Sanjay's mind and the movie
ends as he reminisces the Beautiful
Moments that he got to spend with his
One and Only Love kalpana
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on the notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching